vont s'en remet sur le mardi 13 octobre
merci de vous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de votre actualité locale la nouvelle
majorité de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines vient de délivrer
une conférence de presse pour présenter
le résultat de plusieurs audits internes
des accusations lourdes contre
l'ancienne équipe de gauche une
entreprise yvelinoise labellisé made in
france le groupe christ située dans les
yvelines s'est vu remettre cette
distinction aujourd'hui sur son site de
badens ville pour l'occasion deux
anciens ministres
arnaud montebourg et yves jégo était
présente une nouvelle arme dans la lutte
pour la prévention contre le sida et les
ist l'association née dans les yvelines
hf prévention lancent un challenger game
appelé virus war cette semaine à paris
du 15 au 20 octobre place de la bastille
invité sur notre plateau germandrée
directeur de l'association nous en dit
plus et on débute ce journal par cette
conférence de presse ce matin dans les
locaux de la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonsoir
florane on va juste repréciser de trois
éléments pour bien comprendre un petit
peu de quoi il s'agit mars 2014
élections municipales la droite devient
majoritaire sur saint quentin en
yvelines elle s'empare de
l'agglomération qui était détenu depuis
sa création voici quarante deux ans par
la gauche socialiste communiste
écologiste était aux affaires sans
aucune alternance la droite avec ses
alliés du centre décide en arrivant de
commander des audits il faut dire que le
déficit sur saint quentin en yvelines
est important et que les prochaines
années s'annoncent difficiles avec
notamment la diminution des dotations de
l'état résultats de ces audits des
mesures qui tranche avec la précédente
équipe
la priorité aux entreprises réduction
des budgets alloués à la culture on peut
évoquer la disparition de la maison de
la poésie à guyancourt ou encore à de
celle de l'environnement sur magny les
hameaux dont les missions ont été
attribuées au réseau et des médiathèques
depuis à de ces audits on retenait aussi
l'agitation autour de la question de
promo paul la pépinière d'entreprises on
ne va pas revenir en détail sur cette
affaire puisque des procédures
judiciaires sont en cours
alors le dossier aurait pu s'arrêter là
mais ça m'a
c'est donc un point presse qui a été
organisé avec plusieurs élus de la
majorité le président michel laugier le
premier vice président en charge de
l'économie jean-michel fourgous le
nouveau président de promo paul
justement othman masrouki étaient entre
autres présents ils ont livré de
nouveaux éléments ils ont émis plusieurs
axes aussi de travail pour l'avenir
résumé avec ce reportage sur place
mélanie poquet jeu ça fait quelques
années que je vois ici vous savez le
copinage politique cesser ces terribles
recrutement familiaux et militant voyage
en hélicoptère des élus investissements
à la faveur de la couleur politique des
communes des accusations graves portées
aujourd'hui par la nouvelle majorité de
droite et de centre droite de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
durant un an cinq cabinets d'audit ont
épluché les comptes laissé par
l'ancienne équipe aussi bien dans la
gestion des ressources du même que dans
la gestion des structures satellites ou
encore des finances aujourd'hui les
recrutements ils doivent pas être
partisan ils doivent elles doivent être
sur le les compétences sur sur les
besoins de l'interco pas en fonction des
besoins de telle famille ou de tel parti
donc il faut remettre quand même de
l'éthique et la nouvelle majorité est
désigné à l'issue du scrutin des
municipales de mars 2014 évoqué de
graves dérives et la nécessité de
réorienter l'agglomération vers ses
compétences obligatoires
les priorités s'il développement
économique c'est l'aménagement c'est pas
c'est beaucoup moins je rappelle que 30
% du personnel ici d'utiliser pour une
compétence qui n'est pas obligatoire et
seulement 1% pour une compétence que
l'igad soir donc il faut remettre de
l'ordre là-dedans mise en cause
l'opposition socialiste et communiste
parle de suspicion généralisée et
prépare déjà sa riposte avec un autre
point presse dans les prochains jours
responsable du ps dans les yvelines
sandrine grands groupes dénoncent la
méthode et parle de manoeuvre
électoraliste à quelques semaines des
régionales en dévoilant le contenu des
audits en ce 13 octobre la nouvelle
équipe de l'agglomération s'est engagé
sur plusieurs points diminuer la dette
de 4 millions par an diviser par deux
les effectifs de certains services et
impliquer les entrepreneurs dans la
construction du projet économique la
gauche aujourd'hui dans l'opposition a
donc été la première surprise de cette
conférence de presse ce matin
alors effectivement les élus de gauche
surpris n'était pas présent sur place
bien évidemment ils nous ont dit avoir
suivi via les réseaux sociaux les
discussions puisque chacun des élus
a tweeté un petit peu les différents
éléments écoute et sandrine grand gambe
et lui attrape elle est vice présidente
elle aussi de saint quentin en yvelines
elle est responsable des socialistes
dans le département on n'avait pas
connaissance de cette conférence de
presse ni même du contenu on est
d'autant plus étonné qu'il y avait quand
même une réunion du conseil des maires
hier que président n'a même pas vu les
bandes est d'avertir ses collègues
donc voilà on est un peu étonné à la
fois de la méthode et la manière pour la
communication s'est opéré autour de
cette conférence de presse ce qui
dérange le plus à gauche c'est la
méthode nous sommes à quelques semaines
des élections régionales alors forcément
on s'interroge les lobbys qui vont été
commandée il ya un an et demi et il m'a
été livré un nom pourquoi on a une
conférence de presse maintenant sur des
audits qui ont été rendus il ya un an
effectivement est ce que le problème qui
valent la proximité des élections
régionales explique cela moi je pose la
question mais concernant les accusations
portaient alors au delà des analyses
général effectivement sur le
fonctionnement de l'ancienne équipe ce
matin on a entendu parler de recrutement
familiaux comprenait à des postes
attribués à des proches des élus ou
encore être d'hélicoptères affrété afin
de se rendre sur une étape du tour de
france cycliste forcément des
accusations choc qui vont faire le buzz
et qui font bondir en cette période
économique difficile
voici une fois de plus la réponse de la
représentante de l'âge j'ai jamais
entendu parler de ça je n'ai pas pu
suivre et c'est pas vrai qui c'est vrai
qu'on donne le papier de documents le
vrai document moi je viendrai lecture
crée pas un faux là vous me parlez d'un
document qui est pas surfer est ce que
fait un document qui rêvent que ses
nerfs documents qu'il faut quand j'en
fais rien voyagez pas connaissance de
femmes voilà pour les premiers éléments
autour de cette agitation qui règne
depuis ce matin sur saint quentin en
yvelines et ce n'est pas terminé la
gauche annonce la tenue d'un point
presse demain pour contrer ces
différentes accusations nous y
reviendrons bien évidemment et puis
sachez que sur ce plateau
nous recevrons jeudi soir à 18h en
direct les élus de la communauté
d'agglomération pour vous donner encore
plus d'informations et de détails
merci wilfried autre sujet dans
l'actualité le made in france à
l'honneur dans les yvelines
à bazens ville crise groupe a reçu
aujourd'hui le label origine france
garantie pour l'occasion arnaud
montebourg l'ancien ministre socialiste
et yves jégo ancien ministre ump ont
fait le déplacement ils sont venus
remettre cette distinction à
l'entreprise de verres ophtalmiques pour
son engagement dans l'économie française
sur place camille lambert et patrick
jacques de dixmude à plus de 400
salariés travaillent chaque jour dans
ses locaux
aujourd'hui ils ont eu droit à une
visite peu habituelle arnaud montebourg
a fait le déplacement jusqu'à bazin
ville l'ancien ministre de l'économie
était présent pour la remise du label
origine france garantie aux fabricants
de verres crise groupe
le patriotisme économique a un sens faut
l'encourager je suis un militant du
produire en france du made in france
je suis venu le dire ici chez krys
félicité et encouragé l'entreprise ses
dirigeants ses salariés ses cadres dès
2012 crise groupe s'est imposé comme le
premier fabricant de verres ophtalmiques
à avoir obtenu le label origine france
garantie renouvelé tous les trois ans
après inspection cette distinction leur
a été décerné pour la deuxième fois par
l'association pro france dirigé par le
centriste yves jégo quatre ans après sa
création 500 entreprises sont
aujourd'hui titulaires du label c'est je
crois la certitude pour celui qui achète
que quand ils achètent quelque chose
d'origine france garantie dash est un
produit qui est vraiment fabriquer en
france qu'à créer de l'emploi comme
c'est le cas ici dans les yvelines
derrière c'est les emplois et c'est
l'avenir économique de notre pays qui
est en jeu
nous avons fait un choix stratégique qui
consiste à fabriquer en france nos
verres
et donc pour alimenter ce choix il est
nécessaire d'investir d'investir dans de
nouvelles machines et moderniser et
agrandir notre capacité de production
leader de l'optique en france crise a
investi 12 millions d'euros sur trois
ans pour continuer à développer son
activité dans l'hexagone
bazin ville est un des fleurons du
groupe chaque année plus de 8 millions
d'articles sont expédiés depuis ce site
des yvelines et nous continuons à parler
d'économie et d'emploi l'association
rencontres pour l'égalité d'accès à
l'emploi organisé cet après midi à la
verrière un forum de recrutement les
coups de pouce pour un emploi ont pour
vocation d'aider les jeunes ayant des
difficultés à trouver un travail
âgés de 18 à 35 ans deux sont candidats
se sont présentés devant les recruteurs
18 entreprises ont répondu à l'appel de
l'association parmi elles
auchan carrefour la ratp ou encore le
rdf depuis le lancement de l'association
en 2007
288 jeunes ont été recrutés via ses
forums on écoute tout de suite valérie
d'argenlieu organisatrice de l'événement
coup de pouce pour un emploi au micro de
fanny bourdon
on demande à tous les recruteurs qui
sont là d'évaluer les candidats de nous
dire s'ils vont être reçus ou non à un
second entretien
donc au bout d'une semaine on relance
toutes les entreprises on assure un
suivi des recrutements sur le dernier
coup de pouce qu'on a fait à poissy nous
avons eu 15 embauches et on a encore des
candidats qui sont dans le processus de
recrutement
on espère 10% l'embauchent et ce soir en
plateau avec nous nous allons parler
sont et nous avons deux invités merci à
vous d'être venu germandrée bonsoir vous
êtes directeur 2 h f prévention hf
prévention c'est une association
nationale qui intervient sur la
promotion de la santé en france et
notamment dans les champs des ist et du
syna et jeanine marie bonsoir à vous
vous êtes maire-adjoint ps en charge de
la politique familiale à trappes
vous allez nous parler dans quelques
instants de la 10ème quinzaine de la
nutrition mais nous en tout d'abord
commencé avec vous germandrée vous êtes
venus ici en plateau pour nous parler de
virus soir un événement de promotion du
préservatif et du dépistage vih qui sera
proposée sur l'ensemble du territoire
national et dans un premier temps du 15
au 20 octobre de 10 heures à 20 heures
place de la bastille à paris virus soir
c'est un piège orient quel était le
principal c'est une révolution tout là
pour la france effectivement jusqu'à
présent on avait les serious games les
gens apprenaient donc de manière un peu
sérieuse et s'amuser un petit peu les
challengers games s'est complètement
novateur en france puisque ça vient des
états unis
l'idée c'est que les gens vont pouvoir
s'amuser à détruire le virus du sida
dans une arène de 250 m² en fait c'est
un laser game et puis à côté de ça on va
effectivement leur expliquer ce qu'est
que le vih
comment les gens se contaminent mais
aussi l'intérêt du préservatif et
l'intérêt donc du dépistage l'idée c'est
effectivement de pouvoir leur dire
qu'ils vont aller donc être miniaturisé
projeté dans l'argot note est envoyé
dans le corps d'une personne qui vient
d'être donc contaminé par le virus du
sida et eux-mêmes vont pouvoir lutter
contre le vih
hf prévention a été précurseur là-dessus
l'idée c'est de cette se dire souvent on
dit on est dans la lutte contre le sida
alors en fait on propose aux gens sur le
premier épisode de vraiment lutter
contre le sida il y aura donc trois
épisodes puisque c'est une trilogie
donc j'essaie ludique c'est
pratique c'est un nouveau moyen de
parler aux jeunes oui parce qu'en fin de
compte on se rend compte que donc les
pouvoirs publics le ministère de la
santé liên vs annonce des chiffres
record l'année dernière en tous les cas
donc l'épidémie repart et reprend
surtout sur les moins de 25 ans et les
plus de 45 ans c'est des périodes un peu
charnière à 45 ans et puis regardez
divorce peut dire tout un tas de choses
les moins de 25 ans on se rend bien
compte dans les facultés et c'est qu'il
y a de moins en moins de prévention
c'est effectivement des publics qui sont
extrêmement touchés il convient de
changer aussi nos méthodes de prévention
hf prévention avait déjà innové avec
l'application tube 83 mille
téléchargements et notre marraine marina
carrère d'encausse se félicite
effectivement d'avoir sorti cette
application avec nous pour trouver des
préservatifs mais des lieux aussi donc
de dépistage partout en france et là
l'arrivée des challengers game dans la
lutte contre le sida va un peu
révolutionné les choses puisque c'est
une autre manière de faire la prévention
et puis nos missions sont élargies à
diabète obésité problèmes
cardiovasculaires si bien qu
effectivement ça fonctionne et on
proposera aussi des animations un peu
ludique et interactive sur l'ensemble
donc de ces pathologies
pourquoi selon vous la prévention
habituel traditionnelle est en perte de
vitesse c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui les
moyens de communes amine f-22 de
prévention n'ont pas été réactualisé
aujourd'hui les gens ils ont tous des
smartphones ils ont tous des tablettes
etc
il convient de faire les choses un peu
autrement avec effectivement plus
d'animations ludiques alors c'est vrai
que une fois de plus on est allé aux
états unis pour voir ce qui s'y passait
et ça fonctionne plutôt bien
avant on était dans la prévention
éducative maintenant l'idée c'est
vraiment de changer les comportements
quand on fait du dépistage vih on
s'inquiète aussi de savoir si les gens
derrière vont changer leur comportement
ou du moins on essaye de faire en sorte
que ça puisse être le cas pour avoir une
meilleure adhésion donc à la prévention
est donc c'est un renforcement aussi de
faire des personnes sur le fait qu'elle
puisse être autonome dans leur
prévention
du coup si c'est sous forme de jeu
maintenant aussi ça fait peut-être aussi
un peu moins peur c'est le mieux
également alors le vih ne fait plus peur
aujourd'hui puisque
souvent on entend dire que les gens qui
sont séropositifs sont essentiellement
les gays moi je rappelle nos chiffres la
voyez on est en train de dépister dans
une université pas très loin des
yvelines et effectivement on a des cas
de contamination en moyenne 1,6 pour
cent des gens qui sont des fins qui sont
découverts
donc dans les universités et les centres
commerciaux sont séropositifs je
rappelle que dans le milieu gay c'est à
peu près 1%
nous on est à 1,6 ça prouve quand même
qu'il y a un vrai effort à faire et sur
le port du préservatif et sur le
dépistage et c'est pour ça qu'on incite
effectivement les autres associations à
changer leurs techniques de prévention à
changer leur approche
il faut vraiment aller vers les gens
allaient vers les publics et c'est ce
qui est préconisé en tout cas par le ms
en france environ 150 personnes sont
séropositives et un tiers l'ignorent
est ce que le voilà le nombre de
communautés nos nations augmente oui
parce qu'avant on disait le virus du
sida c'est 6 à 7000 cas de nouvelles
contaminations par an et puis ça a pas
beaucoup ému les gens quand on a 10
entre sept et huit mille parce que après
tout les gens se disaient on est plus à
1000 prévoit l'appui en plus on meurt
plus du sida donc du coup comme il y a
les trithérapies on en meurt plus donc
dans la tête des gens c'est beaucoup
moins grave
alors on n'est pas là pour dire c'est
moins grave c'est plus grave que
d'autres pathologies ce n'est pas le but
du jeu mais c'est vrai que pour le coup
on se rend bien compte que le fait que
les gens ne meurent plus et qu'on ne
meurt plus du sida
si on a les médicaments fait que les
gens ne prennent plus donc la prévention
entre guillemets au sérieux et le fait
d'avoir donc des jeunes qui vont pouvoir
jouer donc dans un game 'changer game ça
va permettre aussi d'avoir un taux
d'adhésion à la prévention beaucoup plus
fort parce que même s'ils se sont amusés
ils ont appris effectivement des choses
des notions qui sont assez simples et
c'est vrai que on avait proposé donc à
la communauté de saint quentin de le
faire et en fin de compte ça se fait à
la mairie de paris donc
avec anne hidalgo notamment ce sera
inaugurée donc vendredi 16 mai sinon
donc c'est du 15 au 20 et puis il ya
déjà donc des villes qui nous ont
contactés pour effectivement faire jouer
les collèges les lycées et c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle parce que du coup
c'est très bien accueilli et ça change
de la prévention habituel une dernière
question vous me disiez tout à l'heure
que vous agrandissez votre chambre
mission à partir de 2016 vous aborderez
donc des sujets tels que l'obésité le
diabète ou les problèmes
cardiovasculaires pourquoi ce choix pour
ça va un peu se passer alors en fait
c'est très simple le vih est un
catalyseur de différentes maladies et
les techniques d'approché d'après enfin
d'achères prévention sont des techniques
d'aller vers effectivement on va vers
les publics on va vers les gens avec des
diagnostics qu'on va poser avant
d'intervenir donc on a un peu devenus
des experts de ça et pour le coup les
champs qui nous ont attribué son des
chants ou effectivement il ya fort à
faire et d'ailleurs quand on parle de la
semaine du goût on parle aussi de bien
faire à manger de bien se poser de bien
comprendre aussi
chaque aliment et c'est vrai qu'il n'ya
pas encore de structure associative qui
oeuvrent vraiment sur le dépistage de
l'obésité et notamment sur adopter les
bons réflexes alors on va voir
effectivement comment on va pouvoir donc
se positionner par rapport à ce qui est
demandé donc par les pouvoirs publics
mais il est vrai qu en tous les cas
c'est pareil pour le diabète il y a
beaucoup d'associations qui gère les
personnes diabétiques en france mais
très peu font de la prévention avant que
les gens ne deviennent diabétiques donc
tout l'objectif d'achat prévention ça va
être comme dans le vih prévenir les gens
avant qu'ils soient effectivement
contaminés par le virus ou devenant
diabétiques ou devenant obèses et puis
les problèmes cardiovasculaires c'est
complètement cohérent par rapport à
l'obésité par rapport au problème
on va on va voir comment ça va se
dérouler mais en tous les cas ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'il nous ait demandé d'avoir
des changeurs game des nouvelles
approches du diagnostic et donc du
dépistage précis de population enfin
voilà donc c'est vrai que pour le coup
hf prévention qui était une petite
association dans les i
line est largement soutenue et
maintenant effectivement une structure
d'ampleur nationale avec des nouvelles
missions alors on va voir comment ça
s'organise mais on a hâte
effectivement d'aller encore plus proche
des populations à chaque formation a
bien grandi je le rappelle l'événement
vireuse voir ça commence le 15 octobre
et c'est jusqu'au 20 la place de la
bastille l'entrée est gratuite et nous
accueillons pour parle également de
prévention mais là en termes de voix la
de nutrition and jeanine marie donc
maire-adjoint ps en charge de la
politique familiale à trappes
je vous voyais réagir par rapport aux
propos de jérôme andré est ce qu'il y
aura été des challengers des challengers
game pardon à trappes fait pas mais en
tout cas la halle d'ateliers organisés
pour la quinzaine d'années tri sion
contracte déjà l'obésité depuis
longtemps la malnutrition aussi on a des
actions dans les écoles depuis une
dizaine d'années où il ya une
diététicienne qui vient apprendre aux
enfants comment faire menus équilibrés
ya le concours de menus ce menu est
mais est affiché et puis dégustées dans
toutes les écoles en même temps on l'a
trois secteurs trimestre et ça tourne
comme ça et les enfants sont très
intéressés par les quilleurs alimentaire
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
penser en raccord en phase avec la
malbouffe le grignotage devant la télé
tout ça les enfants sont très très
intéressé par ça c'est pour ça que plus
tôt on les jeunes plutôt on les prend en
jeunes et plus dans les accompagnent
dans le temps et plus on a des chances
que ça s'inscrit dans leur comportement
alimentaire parce que c'est tout dans
l'habitude des élections qu'ils aient
choisi mettre en place dans le cadre du
plan national santé c'est une obligation
ou de vous vendre un drap vous avez des
sables en dominant non c'est pas une
obligation
on savait partie des priorités que l'on
a envers la population de la ville qui
est souvent démuni sur un certain nombre
d'informations et lorsqu'on voit que au
national l'obésité centre 16 des 17 % 4
ap on est entre 23 et 24 c'est beaucoup
trop même si la pmi nous dise est en
baisse donc on peut penser qu'il ya
quelques effets quelque part mais c'est
encore beaucoup trop 16-17 c'est
beaucoup trop et on le voit bien qu'on
peut on a fait le film days cette
année-là en joie les enfants qui vont
dans la piscine on voit bien que je vous
ai dressé aussi dans le cadre de cette
quinzaine d'années pression il ya
plusieurs ateliers des conférences des
débats qui sont organisées aux parents
aux enfants très jeunes d'ailleurs à
partir de 6 mois mais aussi c'est c'est
aussi aux personnes âgées aujourd'hui à
meetic par exemple vous visez d'un très
large public oui tout à fait c'est
volontaire et on fait ça toute l'année
là il ya une loupe qui est mis sur la
quinzaine avec des ateliers spécifiques
et mais en fait ça toute l'année
toute l'année donc je vous salue la
décision d'aborder le sujet du côté des
seniors
aussi c'est une décision les seniors
aussi ont besoin
bien sûr le nôtre alimenter nos
habitudes alimentaires et les
conséquences de ses habitudes sur la
santé des personnes âgées et par
monsieur parler de wc et de diabète
c'est lié à certains comportements on ne
peut plus manger aujourd'hui comme on
mange et il y a trente ou quarante ans
parce que les produits alimentaires que
nous trouvons ne sont plus les mêmes et
les conséquences sur la santé sont
dramatiques
donc on est obligé de regarder avec eux
comment comment s'alimenter on
s'alimente pas qu'on tombe personnes
âgées comme cantournet 40 ou 50 ou même
60 ans s il ya une nouveauté dans cette
émission par rapport aux précédentes je
trouve je trouve qu'il ya davantage
d'ateliers et c'est plus axé sur le
comportement a changé
et voilà parce que c'est tout et last
dans les habitudes
c'est la clé et puis on a deux troupes
qui viennent enfin un monsieur est une
troupe qui viennent
la première c'est destiné à 600 enfants
il ya trois représentations c'est
complet depuis le départ dès l'annoncé
du du sujet et ça amène les enfants à
s'interroger justement sur le
comportement alimentaire se poser des
questions à se positionner différemment
et puis à court et des pistes de façon à
sortir de ses habitudes
c'est difficile quand tu auras des
copains qui n'ont pas les mêmes
informations pas les mêmes sensibilités
c'est difficile de se positionner en
tant que gamin et de dire non mais moi
je veux pas faire comme ça parce que
voilà ce qu'il ya derrière et baisser
les taux bas tous les effets de groupe
sont négatifs on le sait c'est pas
nouveau
voilà et puis on a aussi toute l'année
le diabète parce que le diabète fait
aussi des ravages
donc la quinzaine de la santé de la
nutrition que ça va aussi aller sur les
vacances de la toussaint donc les
enfants pour en profiter pour aller
justement à participer à ces ateliers
les parents également c'est jusqu'au 23
octobre à trappes
merci en tout cas à vous deux d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation
et on passe à présent aux sports c'était
le match à ne pas manquer pour les
amateurs de football nostalgiques de la
coupe du monde 98 le variétés club de
france composée notamment de laurent
blanc didier deschamps ou encore
christian karembeu a foulé la pelouse du
stade léo lagrange à poissy pour un
match amical
les fonds récoltés ont été reversés à
diverses associations résumé du match
par mickaël mille euros et patrick
jacques de dixmude un match de gala hier
soir au stade léo lagrange de poissy les
anciens champions du monde 98
laurent blanc didier deschamps fabien
barthez et christian karembeu rechausser
les crampons à l'occasion d'un match
exhibition entre le variétés club de
france et la sncf
le match s'est soldé par une victoire du
variétés 4 à 2 avec un triplé du
brésilien sonny anderson
je ne sais pas s'il ya eu un précédent
ici à poissy avec de telles stars prenez
simplement didier deschamps champion du
monde vainqueur de la ligue des
champions avec marseille vainqueur de la
coupe d'europe avec l'équipe de la
juventus de turin
c'est juste exceptionnel ça fait plaisir
de se retrouver y avait du monde donc
tout est parfait vous êtes senti comment
vous sur le terrain
vieillissant pour ce match amical plus
de 2500 spectateurs sont venus garnir
les tribunes ça a remis des émotions
qu'on a eus qu'on a vu en replay qui
n'était pas encore né à ce moment là on
voudrait vous revoir l'équipe de france
en ce moment aussi
les voir en vrai ça fait bizarre
franchement ça me fait chaud au coeur de
voir des joueurs 98 qui viennent jouer
sur notre site à tournon pelouse
sachant que je suis choqué ce fut un
plaisir et ça fait chaud au coeur un
atout les pisciacais de france un match
pour la bonne cause les faux récoltés
pendant la manifestation seront reversés
à l'association urma parrainée par
laurent blanc et l'association plus de
vie présidée par bernadette chirac
ça me fait chaud au coeur vous savez on
a on a du mal actuellement à trouver de
l'argent vous en doutez c'est une crise
économique
bon les gens les gens moins d'argent à
donner aux autres et puis ceux qui en
ont besoin quelquefois il en donne pas
au total la manifestation a permis de
récolter ses 1300 euros pour les
associations et une dernières
informations qui concernent aussi
plusieurs célèbres footballeurs les
protagonistes dont l'ancien
international djibril cissé ont été
arrêtés aujourd'hui dans le cadre de l'
affaire de chantage à présumée à
l'encontre du joueur de l'olympique
lyonnais
mathieu valbuena sont entendus
aujourd'hui à versailles au siège de la
police judiciaire
on ignore encore quels liens précis
peuvent être établies entre les deux
joueurs et les autres protagonistes
arrêtés selon les premiers éléments de
l'enquète en tout cas djibril cissé
devrait être très rapidement mis hors de
cause et c'est la fin de cette édition
tout de suite vous avez rendez vous avec
nour a dit nein pour le 7-8 société
objet du débat commissariat du futur à
quoi ressemblera la police de demain je
voulais ce pour ma part je vous retrouve
demain à 18 heures pour une nouvelle
édition du 7 8 le journal en direct je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée